in the world of jrr tolkien middle earth
itself is as much a character as any of
the story's heroes or villains
now with the release of amazon's
upcoming lord of the rings prequel
fans should expect to return to a few
familiar locations
if there's one place that serves as a
focal point of the entire lord of the
rings trilogy
it has to be mordor this is where sauron
makes his home in middle-earth
and it's where the one ring was forged
too as a result frodo's entire journey
is undertaken with the goal
of reaching the land of shadow from the
stories beginning to its very
end mordor mounts doom and sauron's
tower of bharador are crucial to the
plot
the good news for tolkien fans is that
these are very important locations in
the second age too
an appendix to the return of the king
explains that roughly 1 000 years into
the second age
sauron chooses mordor as a land to make
into a stronghold
its black gates are guarded by more than
just
orcs there is evil there
that does not sleep this is when he
begins the building of bharador
which isn't exactly an overnight project
as it takes a dark lord and his servant
six whole centuries to complete
construction the very year barodor is
finished
sauron enters the forge of o'rourke ruin
and creates his one ring
with all this in mind it seems pretty
much definite that the amazon series
will return to mordor
and give fans a chance to see the
darkest corner of middle earth in its
prime
the elves are far more involved in
middle earth politics during the second
age than they are in the third
at this time one of their most powerful
kingdoms is linden located just to the
west of what will later be known as the
shire
linden is a vastly powerful kingdom
that's ruled by the elven high king
gilgalad whose herald and right hand man
is a young elvish noble named elrond
by the time of the lord of the rings
just a small remnant of gilgalad's
people
remain in middle-earth having maintained
a dwelling of the elvish haven of
midland
also known as the grey havens this is
where frodo and bilbo reunite with
elrond galadriel and gandalf
and set sail into the west at the end of
the return of the king as will be the
case for many of the show's locations
the grey havens of amazon series
will seem very different to how it's
portrayed in lord of the rings
rather than appearing as an md faded
stronghold that quietly ferries elves
across the sea
myth london will likely be a thriving
crossroads and safe haven for all the
free peoples of middle earth
elrond spends many of his early days
serving gilgalad in linden
at one point he leads an army out of the
elvish kingdom to battle the emergent
forces of sauron
when his host is defeated elrond
retreats northward to the edge of the
misty mountains
where he establishes a new stronghold
called eem lardres
also known as rivendell elron's homely
home attracts countless refugees of the
ongoing war against sauron
and eventually becomes a critical base
of resistance
against the dark lord even to casual
fans rivendell is one of the most
recognizable locations in all of middle
earth
both the hobbit and the lord of the
rings make multiple stops at the elvish
refuge
the most famous of which is the council
of elrond drawing the fellowship of the
ring
in all of these cases elron's domain is
depicted as a quiet and
peaceful refuge from the world's many
perils but things were very different
during the early days of eem lardres in
fact elron's fortress remained under
siege for years after it was first
established
painting quite a different picture than
the blissful oasis of khan that fans of
the movies have come to expect
no doubt the show's creators will leap
with the chance to bring the first siege
of em large risk to the screen
giving fans a glimpse of this familiar
location in a very different age
lothlorien is an ancient elvish realm
with various woodland folk having lived
there since the earliest days of their
history
even as late as a second age however the
land looks very different to how it's
portrayed in the lord of the rings
for one thing galadriel and her husband
keller born aren't in charge
at least not initially part way through
the second age galadriel does arrive in
loflorien
but even then as a visitor and not a
ruler the huge silverbacked and
golden-leafed malone trees that define
the look of the third ages lothlorien
aren't there either
as galadriel is the one who initially
brings the seeds for those mighty
arboreal wonders
nonetheless lothlorien plays an
important role in the events of the
second age
the realm is ruled by the elvish leader
named amdia who fights and dies
alongside his kin
during the war of the last alliance so
while this version of lovelorian will
likely have a very different vibe to
galadriel's realm
you can probably make a safe bet that
it'll appear at least once in amazon's
upcoming series
the fellowship's journey to the mines of
moria is one of the most famous
sequences in the lord of the rings
the nine travelers expect to meet
gimli's cousin barlin
but their hopes are quickly dashed when
they discover the dwarven kingdom in
ruins
maurya is also notorious for being home
to durian's bane
the monstrous balrog that gandalf
confronts on the bridge of kaza doom
you know what they awoke in the darkness
of hazard
shadow and flame
in the second age however there's no
fiery demon on the premises just yet
as the dwarven kingdom of kaza doom is
still very much in its heyday
as such during the time of amazon series
all those md hallways and dusty tombs
will be well lit
thriving and positively filled with
dwarves the doors of doom were also
constructed during the second age
that's a kind of collaboration between
the dwarves of kaza doom
and the elvish craftsman of aragian
chief miss keller brimble
the elf prince who forged the three
rings fangorn forest is a unique place
in middle earth
not only is it a dense ancient wood but
it's also the only known place where the
ants still live
during the lord of the rings during the
second age however this sprawling
woodland is much larger and may even
connect with the old forest
which lies directly adjacent to the
shire hundreds of miles away
in the books tolkien frequently hints at
the forests of middle earth may once
have been far deeper than they currently
appear
in the two towers for example tree beard
tells mary and pippin that in the past
i could walk and sing all day and hear
no more than the echo of my own voice in
the hollow hills
in addition at the council of elron's
the learned elf points out
time was when a squirrel could go from
tree to tree from what is now the shire
to dunland west of isengard
in other words frodo's entire journey
from the shire to the walls of moria
took place over a land once filled with
forest
this is no big surprise of course
tolkien was a huge lover of nature
and especially of trees as such it seems
like a fitting tribute to the author
himself to offer viewers a glimpse into
tolkien's great forest
at their absolute greatest nestled at
the northern edge of merckwood the
woodland realm plays a central role in
the
events of the hobbit king thranduil
captures bilbo and his dwarvish
compatriots
during their quest to the lonely
mountain and later plays a crucial role
in the story's final battle
but that isn't the first time that the
woodland elves became entangled in the
affairs of middle earth
in fact by the time of the hobbits the
kingdom has already existed in murkwood
for thousands of years
since the first half of the second age
at this point murkwood is known as the
greenwood
and it's here that thranduil's father a
fur decides to set up sharp
aura first people ultimately get mixed
up in the events of the last alliance
and the elvish king is slain during the
battle of dagolad after this
randywill returns to the greenwood with
the remnants of his army
constructs the great halls of thranduil
and takes his people in the ground for
the next few thousand years
before frodo sam and garland enter
mordor they travel through a path that's
home to mina's mogul
the ghastly city inhabited by the nazgul
and their armies
the tree avoids the city by climbing a
steep mountain stair
battling through shilob's lair and
finally arriving at syria
ungal another fortress built right into
the mountainside
both of these insidious strongholds are
filled with all kinds of evils
but they don't start out that way
they're actually the work of the men of
numenor who built both fortresses to
defend their newly founded kingdom of
gondor
against the forces of sauron while
sirathangal isn't constructed until the
third age
the city at guards has founded towards
the end of the second
easily fitting into the show's timeline
under gondor's role mina's morgul is
known as the minas ethel
the tower of the moon and is supposed to
act as a sister city
to mean as tirith expect to see the
construction of minors ethil
play a significant role in the later
episodes of amazon series
okay let's rip this band-aid off quickly
the truth is there's little to no chance
that you're actually going to see the
shire in the amazon series
at least not as you know it since the
actual hobbit-filled shire
doesn't appear on the map until well
into the third age but that doesn't mean
the land itself can't make an appearance
for one thing the shire lies near
gilgalad's kingdom of linden
which is likely to feature prominently
in the show additionally galadriel and
kellerborn temporarily roll over a
colony of elves in the region
one way or another there's a good chance
we'll get to see those rolling green
hills again
even if they don't have any halflings
living in them just yet
the nearby community of brilland is more
likely to show up in the new show though
this region is well established by the
second age and initially constitutes
part of gondor's sister kingdom of
arnold while it probably won't look
quite the same bree in its fellow
townships could definitely play a role
in the story
when frodo sam and gollum journey to the
dead marshes they encounter some creepy
aquatic ghouls that haunt the vast
mucky quagmire but who were these
spirits and just how do they end up lost
in that forsaken corner of the world
the answer lies in the second age and in
particular the war of the last alliance
this epic confederation of elves men and
dwarves attacked sauron in mordor itself
but before they enter mordor they fight
a huge battle against sauron's forces
before the gates of his domain a great
battle long ago
[Music]
in the two towers gollum explains they
fought on the plane for days and months
at the black gates
but the marshes have grown since then
swallowed up the graves
always creeping creeping amazon's
prequel is almost guaranteed to show
this battle in all its macabre glory
albeit probably not until a much later
season
in the lord of the rings the invasion of
gondor begins with hordes of
orcs invading a ruined city called
ozgiliath from there they attacked the
capital city of gondor at the time
minas tirith except that if you go back
far enough
it's actually us gilead that stands as
the capital of the nation
minas tirwith meanwhile is simply a
tower fortress
built to help protect the nearby city if
amazon's show depicts the fall of
numenor and the establishment of gondor
which it almost certainly will it's
likely to feature a much more impressive
version
of the city of ozgiliath from there the
chance to explore the surrounding lands
of gondor and the budding towers of
manasse tirith
will be just too epic for amazon studios
to resist
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the lord of the rings are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you